que pouvons nous dire ce matin de
nouveau bonjour d'abord bonjour bonjour
je travaille la salle et vous c'est vous
dire bonjour important c'est de se dire
bonjour bonjour l arbre votre candidate
pas terrible non vous n'êtes pas
s'emballer
vous venez tous me taper
vous endettez personnellement à hauteur
de 5 millions d'euros valérie pécresse a
lancé un appel à l'aide et aux dons mais
sur les réseaux sociaux les internautes
se paye la candidate heller son affiche
de campagne et détourner cet ancien
tweet opposant travail et assistanat et
massivement relayé commenter certains
sortent tout de même le chéquier pour un
montant de 0 euros heureusement un
ancien concurrent vole à son secours un
don de jean lassalle avec en cadeau un
conseil on a souvent besoin d'un plus
petit que soi d'où vous est venue cette
soudaine générosité pour les les partis
qui sont endettés mais d'un moment de
joie je dois dire parce que nos arrières
soit un comité de campagne et il y avait
le trésorier il a mangé des chéquiers et
me porte le chéquier et puis je jure la
journée en dents voilà je suis dit après
tout pourquoi pas valérie pécresse peut
aussi compter sur le soutien de l'ancien
trader jérôme kerviel un temps d'été à
hauteur de 5 milliards d'euros et tomoko
il y en a un qui détient et à
[Musique]
la rigueur
j'aimerais rappeler qu'à ce qui fait
appel au secours ces dérives et
quelqu'un dit je crois que c'est de mes
enfants ouais mais on ne veut lui donner
un coup de main vous avez fait un don de
combien on a tous envie de savoir
ce dont tu ne le dit pas et nous on a la
zale
encore
cette décharge est devenu le restaurant
quotidien d'un couple de cigognes du
coup elles ont changé leur mode de vie
comme elle on a mangé toute l'année
elles ne font plus le grand voyage vers
l'afrique elles sont devenus sédentaires
mon dévolu
sur gonis
classe élite vous êtes manipulateur et
vous êtes monteur
[Musique]
jamais
vu c'est quoi les faits on a été pris et
des moins que rien des délits en mai
vouloir respecter un monsieur que
l'autre oui oui vous êtes un gros
caca alors on vous entendez pas ma
chérie on nous entend pas ma chérie metz
alors peut donner un micro au micro pour
la jeune fille s'il vous plaît comme ça
en cinq voilà
qui vient du mondial de la coiffure
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe à chéri et
moi ma chérie qu'est ce qui se passe ta
déchirer ta carte en fait on dirait ma
carte j'ai déchiré ma carte là des
lecteurs j'en ai vu un président d'un
cinquième république
je vous remercie d'avoir plein
d'arguments un médecin david
est basé sur l'hôpital roddenberry d'or
est un matériau total sur l'hôpital en
avons mis en harmonie j'ai remis les
biens cynisme il vient d'arriver un
candidat qui a peur de tout et qui
calcule tous les risques mais pourquoi
il est candidat est-ce qu'il n'aura pas
de risque qui sera président en a déjà
été on a vu ce que ça donnait tous les
sujets sains n'ont pas été traités comme
ils avaient pu l'être et ce type là la
scoumoune alors que moi j'ai la baraka
je la vois un gars et la différence est
conscient que je regrette encore une
fois devant être original ne pas devenir
président à une très belle équipe et un
très beau projet moi je vous respecte
vous dites des choses qui sont très
maigres et vous respecte aussi mais je
vois jamais mais je l'entends simplement
c'est pas très argumentée au nom des
chiites 60
tous ces cas sont le tout vous traîner
derrière que ce soit d'enfer been à la
[Musique]
mcb colère votre petit copain là j'avais
secrétaire général est joué vous êtes
mélange quand même beaucoup dans la tête
par oui
du centre est toujours en marche le gros
des effectifs a réussi à passer